we've come a long way from Superfriends
haven't we
what once was a joke of a movie from
Entourage has now become a multi-million
dollar worldwide hey the suit will not
look like that on film
Tom crazy like four on screen he looks
like Yao Ming yes Aquaman is here and
it's filled with plenty of small nods to
the wider world beyond just DC Comics
here are some of the small details in
Aquaman you may have missed and if you
haven't seen the movie yet stick some
seaweed over your eyes you dummy
there's spoilers in these waters when
Atlanta and Tom Aquaman's aqua mom and
aqua dad meet for the first time we got
a glimpse into some of the ways Tom
liked to spend his free time you know
when he's not rescuing washed-up mer
women from the rocks down near the edge
of his lighthouse if any movie goers
watched a lot of serial children's TV in
the 1960s they might have noticed that
Tom had an episode of stingray playing
on his television that is right before
Atlanta through her Trident through it
once she regained consciousness stingray
for those who aren't familiar concerned
a heroic submarine crew that discovers
civilizations secretly living on the
oceans floor and the high adventure
hygiene set ensue as a result of that
discovery all things considered it's a
pretty fitting television choice for Tom
it may be a little on the nose
eagle-eyed fans might have spotted a
book featuring the works of HP Lovecraft
on one of Tom's tables while Lovecraft
is known for lots of weird contributions
to horror and pop culture his best-known
invention is probably Cthulhu an ancient
type of cosmic sea monster who has a
whole bunch of tentacles on his octopus
face the various civilizations we see
throughout Aquaman as well as the secret
ocean in the center of the world and
particularly the sea monster who guards
at limbs tridents all seem to be at
least partially inspired by Cthulhu and
the rest of Lovecraft's creepy writing
while Aquaman director James Wan may not
necessarily be a household name just yet
fans of horror movies are extremely
familiar with his work Juan became well
known for his work on the conjuring
movies which feature a pair of
paranormal investigators who well go and
investigate the paranormal and one of
those creepy supernatural things is the
Annabelle doll which viewers could spot
sitting near Meera ship shortly after
she brings Arthur down to the ocean to
begin their adventure
and that's not the only reference back
to the conjuring series of movies
Patrick Wilson who played teen arm has
appeared in both conjuring films as Ed
Warren who's based on a real-life ghost
chaser from which the movie franchise
takes its inspiration and while we're on
the subject of Patrick Wilson this isn't
even the first time he's appeared in the
Warner Brothers superhero movie back in
2009 he appeared as night owl and Zack
Snyder's Watchmen adaptation Randall
Park made a couple of memorable
appearances on Aquaman's fictional TV
Network GBS of dr. Steven Chen even for
Aquaman shin is pretty obscure compared
with the rest of the characters comics
history Shin debuted in 2011 DC Comics
reboot as an ally of Arthur's but shin
comes into conflict with Arthur when the
hero refuses to reveal the secret
location of Atlantis based on the film's
single post-credit scene where shin and
black manta seem to team up chances seem
good that shins role will be expanded by
quite a bit and the eventual sequel